Okay. I feel myself
tense up in those moments that I was
thrown before I thought I would be
throwing. Like Virginia had a couple of
spirals that really caught me. And I
could feel what I thought was relaxed
initially. I could feel all that go away
in that moment of surprise. Yes.
The uh here's a another thing to think
about.
Um,
let me try to give you some context for
that before I ask you to see yourself.
You you know,
usually
I just keep usually I just keep a single
and get along. I'm trying to teach
something and make you feel it and not
go around.
because I want to make the point
and you see me do that. The UK is not
going to let me make the point that I
actually
saw once I think it was shot was not
like I would
make the point. Okay. So you it's not
uncommon and hence on all the videos you
see it's either was Tristan the whole
time, it was Taylor the whole time and
was running the whole time. Okay. And we
don't film everything. It's just
We we do this cuz uh I don't remember
someone asked for it last camp to show
the whole class. We have the whole
class. Tell you the truth, it worked out
a lot easier. Although the loading takes
a long time. The editing takes a long
time. So just like I'm tired, too, and I
don't want to go home and try to edit. I
would never finish it. Okay, it's just
easier.
Put some fade in, fade out. Now I just
got to wait for it to get on on the
channel. Okay. But
so whatever amount of throws that you're
seeing, you can see that they can just
keep coming in and coming in and coming
in. And of course, we already did the
kids class and we already did the body
conditioning and we already did the
grappling and then they're doing that.
Um,
and you could keep that in mind. It'll
look like they're getting tired.
Now go to where was was I getting tired?
I was able to relax on the naga side but
on the side I was getting tired. That's
where I got winded four reps in and I
wanted just to stop. Okay. And it's
because this tension if you think about
it if I'm not doing anything I don't
have to ground at all. You have to move
my body the whole time.
Uki should be where I'm even more
relaxed. Okay. But it can't be because
UKI has more unselfing requirement
than even the numbers. Okay.
Because of the loss of control that I
feel from it. Okay. The unpredictability
all that kind of stuff.
And again you can just see the egoic
drive to actually want to be
choreographed.
Right.
But I see view
as I do get that it's higher. I do
understand the desire in the in the
desire to show somebody the desire to
feel powerful. I get that. But there's
more
fear in the loss of control.
The egoic mind is really working
overtime on that in that part. UK and so
for me uk is the kind of death
meditation
and to be honest when I do the my level
of zen but the zen that I'm showing you
guys is what I would teach at the
beginning of zen okay the level of zazen
that I do is I would say for my
religious studies it's a death
meditation
so in a way I am trying the way that
you're trying to release your muscles
and your tissues and all that stuff. I'm
trying to release my
life seed. See if I can let that go.
That that's what I'm releasing in there.
whatever you think was released when you
can get to this death meditation. Like I
can do a quick physical release but I
get deep in that meditation of the death
meditation where
I don't know if I'm breathing or not.
That's when you feel like oh it just
feels everything. It's really pushing on
me.
I can't tell
if that gravity is suffocating me or I'm
not needing to breathe anymore. I don't
know what the hell that is. Okay. But I
do know when I go and do biking,
um,
that's what it feels like for me to stay
as relaxed as possible with certain
nuggets who are going to throw me, you
know, no matter what is going to happen.
I I go into that state
and then I don't get tired
because they're doing all the work. In
fact, it gets tiring for them because
I'm more relaxed now. I'm heavier than
ever a lever.
And you guys have all this. Okay.
Um,
well, I would still as much as I need it
for, you should try to do it as nuggets
here. Okay? Try to surrender, try to
release, try to accept, try not to
protect.
This is why
again the tension is of course going to
interfere with the force engine. Of
course we already know that.
But the tension is a symptom
of the anxiety. Let's call it that. And
the anxiety is a symptom of the self.
If I don't make that selfieing
the centrality of my khan, then my khan
cannot be that middle ground.
That's a place where I'm still working
on the contestation with the voice.
And this to me is why this this style of
training with that structural
understanding of where everything fits
between cultivation fields and
application fields and all that kind of
stuff. This type of training can
actually work on my spiritual maturity.
I can actually be nonviolent now.
because I cannot be unconsciously
habitually triggered into violence
and the same thing would happen even
amidst violence. So take take this
example we have the taser in law
enforcement and we call that uh non-dely
force or less lethal force. I've seen
that thing used very violently.
Maybe you've been in a pillow fight
with your brothers or your friends
and think pretty freaking violent, too.
The tool itself is not what makes me
violent or nonviolent.
Right now, what modern Iikido is trying
to be a nonviolent tool and then you
don't have to actually work on yourself
because we're not going to actually give
you any way of working on yourself.
But this other way
makes training very hard.
I just want to exercise.
Okay.
But this is the way that kimon can be
concentric to zen, which can be
concentric to karma yoga, which can be
concentric to I'm just a guy
who works the fairy at the river
and I'm just like the Buddha.
Well, if that's all true, and I know
it's true, just like Young knows,
it is very problematic.
When I'm here and I'm having responses,
cannot leave. Cannot believe. Now,
because we are progression based and we
are what we are, we always kind of
Keep it going.
Keep it going, right? But okay, try
again tomorrow. Okay, try again
tomorrow. But in you, you have to make
sure it's on the table of what you're
going to try not to do and what you're
going to try to do and not just keep
going down range, not just keep doing
that rep again like that.
In here I've mentioned we have a policy,
we have a etiquette, we have we have an
NRT
says it in there
be expelled from the dojo. Basically
it's a divorce clause because it's sens
relationship. It's like a marriage to me
and now means I'm going to suffer
through everything that you're making me
suffer through because you refuse to do
this or that. But at a certain point,
you're now going to be deemed not
responding to training and then we get a
divorce on the phone. Okay?
But it should never reach that way. Just
like it should never be no one should
ever be called out by a sensei rule. You
see, no one should that's the sensei
rule. No one should ever do that.
Everyone should be from the inside. And
I felt my emotional reactivity and that
I got to get rid of that. I got to
figure this out. Or I felt my shoulder
tight. I got to get rid of my shoulder
tight. I felt my push back on them. I
got to get rid of that. Got to get rid
of that. Okay.
Otherwise, how in the world can I ever
improve on on any concentric level? What
what would be what would be the metric
for
a positive transformation if I don't do
anything about what I
Okay.
So,
it takes a lot of awareness, a lot of
self-observation, but yes, a lot of
discipline, yes, a lot of grit.
And I'll tell you this, those things are
way more important than who your teacher
is, whatever lineage you're in. Without
those things, it doesn't really matter
who your teacher is. Okay? And I would
say, I know it seems weird, but with
those things, again, it doesn't matter
who your teacher is.
There's not really anything
that we've talked about so far this week
that isn't in isn't talked about in
idea. Nonestation, that's not I didn't
invent that. Cooko, I didn't invent
that. I didn't invent that.
Calm spirit, I didn't invent that.
Self release, I didn't invent that.
These nothing's nothing's new.
It's just we're holding ourselves to
those things.
What does that mean? What what is co?
Everyone will say it's fascia or
whatever. You know,
you're like, "Well, then I already got
it cuz I was born with fascia." Okay?
You know what I mean? Like everything is
like that. Like it was, "Oh, it's
timing." Okay, got it. Timing.
No, timing is hard. You can't ever get
timing. Then why do I do it? Why do I
work for it?
Or they go, "This is nonviolent.
I don't know about that." Cuz
have you been thrown on the street?
And you can knelt down on the street.
Even like when we t the officers, they
love to do they like to take people down
with their own body weight. Kind of like
Jimmy W because they have no technique.
So they try to get as much mass in the
take down.
And then you have to tell them, okay,
we're just taking advantage of the math.
Let's hit the grinder. The grinder is a
concrete thing. Everyone feels one time
slowly and then not even a second time.
Okay? Do you know what I mean? No,
nobody goes, no one goes like this.
The first time they're like this and
then they don't even do it anymore.
Okay.
And again, you try to tell them in
training, hey, I know I'm telling you,
you don't do that. I know I personally
know an officer who knelt down like that
blew his kneecap out and it disable.
Don't do it. It doesn't work in the
street.
How many of you have slapped on the on
off the map? Right. Okay. Very similar,
right?
It's kn even worse. Okay, just imagine
your UK.
It's so weird. What? If if it's not,
then why do I have a padded surface at
all?
The karate sisters, they don't have
pads. They have wood floor. It's that
floor like that. We train on that floor.
I've showed you the shi. They train on
the wood floor, too. They don't have any
problem thinking that was a nonviolent
because it hurts even though they're
dispersing energy. And they know how
much training went into it. And they
know they got selected for this
demonstration because they can hit the
throw without dying.
Again, all we're doing here is just
truly asking why, why, why, how, how
how, how, all the way to the end till I
actually have the answer.
And the answer is the shape of an
experience.
And when you do that, why, why, how,
how, there's no way that a non that
there's such a thing as a nonviolent
martial art. There's just not. And
there's no way that I can solve within
me my own propensity towards violence,
towards reactivity,
in my own will to power by giving me a
tool. There's no way.
And we're just going, okay, now that
there's no way, how do you do it? How
would you actually do it if there's no
way?
And now we do keep on that way.
Unself unself unself unself.
And one of the key places is a new
because that is really pushing on us the
loss of control
and because we know that spiritually
that is one reason why we cannot do
this. the choreography can
cannot do it. So now we have to train
ourselves to be able to be thrown
safely.
Okay? We're going to have to get strong.
We're going to have to get fit. We're
going to have to be mobile.
We're going to have to in all our daily
life, we're going to have to
problematize fear. All our anxiety, all
our fear, all our will to disengage, all
our will to retreat.
We're that's on the table. Now,
we're going to call you out, Charlie.
I don't care how old you are.
Charlie was a little kid that was
playing games.
sometimes too
in my will to stay in control
and the fear that's behind it.
I mask it with the morality.
[Music]
You see? So I go I am I am unself
because I wouldn't hit anyone.
You know what I mean?
But we went deeper
to the why y why y why why
we realized that's not the only kind of
violence.
That's not the only violence at all.
And when I try to define violence
deeply, eventually you're going to end
up where we end up. this self-construct.
I have this thing. You know, I told you
earlier today that Mary and I come from
totally different cultures.
We had just we also have the ethnic
culture.
Get just to get you the full party.
share some of my
I I always tell say to everyone Mary is
my
best you can like she teaches me the
most about non-confestation
and I I I know now why marriage is a
sacrament in the ancient Catholic church
on par with the priesthood
because
To marry unto Christ, to be a servant
unto God, you have to unself. And to be
married unto death, you have to unself.
So, here we are. We're from different
cultures, different ethnicities, and
different uh uh economic classes. We
grew up, some of you are not from the
United States. I grew up with government
American cheese. So if you don't have
enough money and the government gave you
some cheese, I don't know you supposed
to survive on American cheese. Okay, we
had American cheese in the fridge,
right?
And uh one time, you know, we were
having Thanksgiving and we Mary and I
were just dating and Mary came over,
invited her to this dinner. My my family
is like the movies you see. Oh, you're
at the house. You're in the family. She
doesn't know us from nothing, right?
We're all hugging her. All these
Hispanics and talking to her about
everything. And then a a discussion
happens. But from various cultures, this
discussion Sounds like an argument.
Okay. But from my culture, everyone
talks at once. And if you want to be
hurt, you're going to have to raise your
volume up. Otherwise, you can't be hurt.
And right. And I'm not even paying
attention cuz no one is fighting.
She ends up leaving the table crying and
goes into the bathroom.
And I'm I'm like I'm not even paying
attention. And my mom is saying to me,
she goes, "Where's she go? Where's she
going? Where's she going?" I go, "I
don't know. To the bathroom."
And then my mom goes,
"Go see if she's throwing up
cuz Mary was really skinny.
I think she's throwing up the dinner.
She's too skinny." And I I got to go cuz
she's not going to let me talk anymore.
And I go, Hey, are you all right? And
she's crying, "No, everyone's mad and
everyone's fighting." No, no, no one's
fighting. Okay, no one's fighting
now. She just she jumps in. Okay, it's
fine. Now she talks too loud for her
family. In fact,
so
here we are. We're getting to know each
other, right? You have kids. And then it
actually brings more self
unself because now the kids too need the
sacrificing of self. You need to serve.
You have your karma yoga here.
You're tired. Doesn't matter. You're
tired.
You're sick. It doesn't matter if you're
sick.
You have to serve.
I can't carry this because this has to
be carried.
If you didn't unself, you would be going
and saying to yourself, I deserve this
rest.
But to take that rest now, this person
can't
be helped.
To me, that's a worse kind of violence.
And when you look at this child who you
were resting or you were entertaining
yourself or you were having ladies night
or what have you
cuz you needed distraction from this
world, we already know.
We already know the science is in. We
already know that child has been hurt
damaged and I never laid a hand on
Where is that violence? What's the
source of that violence? I would say
it's a worse violence.
It's a worse violence because we get
away with it. Because culturally we've
accepted it.
Somehow physical violence made some
difference.
And so we do violence as I understand it
and I'm telling you about it now. We do
it all the time. It just there's no
moral code against it. Now we do it more
freely. But it's worse.
It's worse. It's worse cuz there's no
moral code against it.
So it's not enough if I just say to
myself, I would never hurt hit someone.
It's not enough. It's not enough. It's
nowhere near enough.
And if you remember
this is only for this part of the
training.
You try that at this part. You try
to say I'm following the earthly laws
voice.
This voice does not follow earthly.
And even on this side
where you're in a field, an application
field,
I I have
had to use physical
physical violence on someone. what we
would call physical violence on someone
who we could have killed legally
probably should have
like if I was teaching someone
for officer safety
should have took the shot
but it's relative to what's your skill
do you see now I didn't take the shot I
did grappling instead.
Guy was high, high as hell.
And I knew he wasn't all there.
Got him down. Got him under control.
Everybody's freaking out.
All the other cops. The death right
there. See death right there. All the
other cops.
I remember one backup deputies running
at me with his weapon actually pointed
at me cuz he lost track of where
everything is. And I was having and I'm
like, "Don't shoot him." And I had him
in the in the control and he snapped out
of it. And then everyone knew, "Okay,
Dave. Daddy has them and we're slow
down. Slow down. Okay. Everyone's okay.
We're all okay. We're all okay.
That's nonviolence.
We get him.
He can't go to the jail cuz he's too
high. He has to go to the hospital.
You can't put people in medical
emergencies inside the jail. Go to the
hospital and the doctor has to clear
them.
So we're in the jail. We're in the
hospital. They give him the dose of some
drug to counter out the meth he's on.
It's not working. They give him another
dose. We're there all freaking night.
You're you're in charge of his safety at
this point. We're there all night long.
He finally so up and the next morning.
Okay.
That whole time he's handcuffed to the
bed and he's yelling at me and cursing
me and he's going to rape my life and
I'm a dirty Mexican and all this kind of
You see him with just no
emotional reactivity there.
He's all sober and it's not the same
guy.
Is he the guy that did all those things
and said all those things and caused all
those things? Yes. But no,
not right now.
All right, sir. They cleared you. We're
going to go take you to jail now.
Is there anything you need from here?
Anything you want from here?
Okay, we'll take that, too.
Get to the jail
this way, sir. No beating him up. No
anger at him. Nothing. This is non
violence.
The booking deputy goes, "Okay, you're
good.
All right,
you take care, sir." I'm leaving.
He's all by. He says, "Bye." You know,
my like, "All right, you take care of
Lot." But then as I'm walking out here,
he's a deputy. And I turn around and he
goes,
he says, "Thanks for not killing me.
I knew you could have you probably
should have."
Okay, that's nonviolent. Amish violence.
That's true. nonviolence.
Wrapping myself in a moral code or
wrapping myself in some art, that's not
nonviolence.
So for all these reasons, I really have
to pay attention to my fear on the mat,
myself being on the mat, even when I
mask it with some moral
thing, you see, some worldly code like
it's nonviolent. I'm being nonviolent. I
never hit someone.
I would never.
And instead understand it just as my own
humanity.
There's a part of me
that wants and needs power, wants and
needs control.
But there's another part of me that
doesn't want nor need power or control.
And to understand that it's a skill
that it's not a state I reach. It's a
skill I have. A skill in what? A skill
in unself.
And so as a skill and unself, I practice
it over and over. I do the training
equations over and over and over and
over every day.
So I had I felt the fear. I felt the
tension. I do the death meditation and I
just accept what's happening. All I got
to do is not let my head hit the mat.
I'm going to be okay.
Accept. Feel them. Feel the force.
Except
same thing as no.
Stop. Stop.
Stop the training. Go back and do it.
Don't go into pasti state cuz that's
that worldly dressing. He's saying
that's not it either.
In a way, the weird way
the reconcili reconciliation of our will
to power allows for power without the
will to power. It's very strange.
So the technique both feels soft and
hard,
strong and weak both feels that way.
Fast and slow, you see, because it's
reconciling the dichotoies. And so it
does feel powerful and effortless,
not powerful and effortful.
But I have to be the one to reel me in.
I got to reel me in. And here that's the
expectation.
I don't care how
slow you go, how many times you start
over. That's going to keep us in better
graces. And if you're just unconsciously
practicing selfing or you're
unconsciously masking
your lack of power with the moral code,
you see
this is also not what we do. And I think
the best place to do it is student
because it's so